What way should I adopt to study
comparative religion? If there are your
lectures in which you have taught the
way so please share the
link. The brother said that he has
studied the Quran. He wants to study
comparative religion. So can I guide
him? Which lecture should you refer to?
Is there any talk of mine? Any program
where I teach about comparative
religion?
There are many of my talks, my published
lectures which are on comparative
religion and there are books written by
me since you are from Pakistan in the
religions that you should concentrate
more on comparative religion are
Hinduism and Christianity. These two
religions are the religions which are
maximum followed besides Islam. So if
you want to study compassion with
Hinduism, my talk on similarities
between Hinduism and Islam is a very
good talk. You can even refer to my talk
on Mhammed sallallahu alaihi wasallam in
the way religious scriptures. You can
refer to my talk on Mhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam in the Hindu scriptures.
There's also a talk of mine concept of
God in major world religions regarding
Christianity. You can refer to my talk
as well as my book on similarities
between Islam and Christianity. You can
refer to my lectures on Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam in the Bible
and the other lectures and books on
concept of God in major religions.
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam in
the various world scriptures and various
lectures of mine are there on compact
religion like salah the programming of
righteousness.
These talks if you hear it is mainly
based on one of the important verses of
dawa where Allah says in the Quran in
surah Iran chapter number 3 verse number
64 paper of
book come to common terms as you which
is the first
term that we
worship that we associate to partners
with
that we erect not from among ourselves
lords and pit other than Allah then if
you turn
back that we are Muslims to Allah
subhanaa tala so this is the master key
for Allah
says come to common terms as you so
while giving dawa to a non-Muslim it's
very important that if you start with
common terms
Inshallah you'll be able to break dice
and you'll be successful. So you can
start talking about common terms and
Allah reminds us here in this verse the
most important is
Allah that we worship them but
Allah that we associate no partners with
him. While you're doing dawa, you can
start with things which are common. For
example, science or maybe literature or
whatever you feel is common between the
person you're speaking and yourself or
the religion who you're talking about
and Islam. But your main aim should
be. You may convince them to be
truthful. You may convince them not to
have alcohol. You may convince them not
to have poke. But if you do not remove
the shik from the life of your friend or
the person you're talking to the dwa is
useless the most important is you can
talk about other things but the most
important story if you're not able to
remove the shik from his life if you're
not able to
instill is so in comparative religion
the most important point of compassion
religion is the concept of god in the
world religions if you speak to a
Christian if you try and prove
from the Bible. First you have to prove
that Jesus Christ peace be upon him, he
never claimed divinity. And you can
prove from the Bible and I say that in
my talk and in my book there is not a
single unequal statement in the complete
Bible where Jesus Christ peace be upon
himself says that he is God or he says
worship me and you can hear my talks. So
similarly when you're doing dawa to a
Hindu your first concept should be that
you should remove the idol worship from
the life of the Hindu prove to him that
according to the Vedas there's one god
you should worship him alone almighty
god has got no image so your first
aspect of dawa is concept of one god
that you worship him alone and no one
else so while doing dawa this is the
most important aspect so first you
should master the commonalities between
the concept of God and Islam and other
religion and try and win him over to the
second most important aspect while doing
dawa which is the pillar of Islam. First
pillar we bear a witness that there's no
god but Allah and we witness that
prophet Muhammad is the messenger of
Allah. The second aspect of dawa is to
prove to the non-Muslim that prophet
Muhammad is the last and final messenger
of Allah subhanaa tala. You can start
with proving him about science. If you
think he's a man of science, no problem.
But your final goal should be first.
Second is the prophet Muhammad is the
last and final messenger. As I mentioned
earlier, I've given talks on this topic.
Muhammad peace be upon him in the Bible.
Muhammad peace be upon him in the Hindu
scriptures. Muhammad peace be upon him
in the world religious scriptures. And
then you can go on for a salah and
various aspects but these two are the
most important aspect. And if you're
able to convince the non-Muslim on these
two aspects, he can enter the fold of
Islam. The remaining will follow. As far
as knowing the structure or how should
you do well in compass religion or how
should you do dawa, I would advise you
that you can visit our platform
Alhidaya. Alhaya is the largest Islamic
video on demand platform in the world.
It has the largest number of Islamic
courses in the world. There are more
than 200 Islamic courses on that out of
which many of the courses are by me and
many on comparative religion and there
are thousands of hours of Islamic videos
on this platform. This platform
absolutely free you can visit it and
there is a course which is called as
let's become effective
di the
international dhawa training program.
It's a long course and if you take this
course the study guide there are
questions inshallah that will help you a
lot in the comparative region and will
help you to become a good guy also. Hope
that answers the question.